very confident which sets him up in good
shape when he's playing the world's best
and uh okay
we have a first move queen's pawns have
both moved forward and okay
will we see i was gonna say the job of
our london system will the bishop
develop itself out the dark sky bishop
hans niemann did a chessable course on
this opening recently yeah he did
there's also a big favor of simon
williams aha the joe bava london that's
true actually hans nimon he has a
chesable course on this opening when
will we see if it is the job of london i
think if white develops his dark squared
bishop now if he develops it as he has
just done this is the java london system
it's
technically slightly different because
black's knight is normally developed out
instead of his bishop i think aronian
maybe has studied nemo's chess ball
course maybe he knew this opening was
coming so he tried to avoid it but
either way this set up for white with a
queen side knight out on this square
with a queen side bishop out on this
square
that is the draba london system and it's
very rare actually because until this
last move white had developed the queen
side pieces but not the king side pieces
normally in chess we see the vice versa
we see the other way around the king's
eye pieces develop out so that the white
king can castle and hans he's made up
for that now by bringing his knight out
white's king is ready to shuffle across
to safety
and uh
it's very solid from both sides so far
no real tension with the pawns that's
quite again quite rare for such an
opening especially a queen's pawn
opening and i've got to give credit to
hans because he did a chessable course
on the opening and some people they
create courses they they write opening
books but they don't practice what they
preach hans has been playing it against
the top players over the board online
he's really testing out this opening
trying to make it into a fearsome weapon
and i remember from chesapeal monsters
when we talked a lot about openings
the rule was kind of find out what kind
of style you have and then dig into the
openings that fit that style so what
kind of players should study hans
niemann's
job of london course that is uncheckable
yeah i think the beauty of the job of
london system is firstly there's not
actually so much opening theory there's
not much that you have to sit there and
memorize it's more just about feel all
you need is you need to know the first
three moves from there it's just about
general plans you can freestyle where
the pawns go which pawns to push where
do the pieces belong sometimes you've
got to make a decision which side to
castle here he's castled on the king
side often you actually end up castling
on the other flank
um so it's players who like flexibility
it's players who don't want to get too
deep into the kind of
um the academic side of chess where you
just have to memorize you have to note
down all the moves work out all the
variations at the end it turns out to be
a draw nope there's no forcing draw
variations in this one
and also fighting chess index we talked
about it's for fighting players
and i think that's why it's so it's so
popular that specific opening at amateur
levels at tournament player club player
levels
and uh all the way up to grand master
level clearly wow yeah one of the
benefits of studying an opening like
this is that a lot of people just don't
have the time to dedicate themselves to
studying all these main line openings
which have like 20 moves or theory or
something and they're very cutting edge
and so they said no we don't want that
so we're going to scratch that and play
something that we can learn and master
in a short space of time and as david
says it's flexible and the big thing
that i would say is just know where your
pieces are going to go know what's your
typical pawn breaks and you should be
fine in fact it's a good rule of thumb
for every single opening know where your
pieces go know which ones are the sharp
lines dedicate some time and energy to
fixing that
and then play wow with confidence
and there are different types of
openings i mean one of your favorites
ivanka the karo khan um that one in some
variations you have to know 20 moves of
theory you have to memorize 25 moves
deep just to get a playable position the
jaba london system you know three moves
and you're okay and then from there you
might not get an opening advantage you
might not win quickly but you've got a
good position full of potential um so
it's it's a stylistic thing and we
should mention three of the
most famous grandmasters who play the
opening on a regular basis hans niemann
uh jobavah himself and simon williams
they're all very attacking players
they're all very creative so it allows
that the flexibility gives room for
creativity yeah okay so if you do like
attacking
if you want a flexible opening and if
you don't want to spend too much time
going 20 moves deep if three moves is
good for you
then the job of london is the perfect
opening for you and you can study it
with hans niemann on chessable
i think that sounds like the opening for
me yeah yeah i think so yeah so too you
know just something where you have a
setup where you know where the pieces go
yeah and you know your way to attack
it's important and yeah you're off
and kaya i've beaten gary kasparov with
the java london system it was only a
blitz game but still uh i managed to
beat him uh twice actually with the
opening beaten gary kasparov only in
blitz but uh that's not only it was kind
of practice friendly games and
he got really annoyed actually when i
started playing the opening he was like
don't you want to learn some proper
openings
but uh yeah eventually he figured it out
and then he beat me in the third time
but still oh wow that's how cool well
talking about yeah sorry it works best
against players who rely a lot on
opening preparation and gary kasparov
does uh just do that
so well
gary casparo even he lost to david wow
very cool david but he is a he is a
great champion in history and we are
asking about this today who's your uh
who do you uh hold as the biggest
champion in chess history yeah has
anyone answered derek has borrowed yeah
we have actually it's like you read my
my spreadsheet in front of me and yeah
shokan says that uh for them the best
chess champion is kasparov he was
competing with karpov during the big
changes in the soviet union and the
whole world and for many people he's not
only a talented chess player but an
agent of change he is still a fighter
for dramatic democracy and freedom
uh-huh meanwhile sorry ivanka but we
have seen hans niemann i think he was
cursing himself a moment ago he was
talking to himself
slapping his face he has just blundered
a pawn we were praising the
above the london system
and the opening actually worked out very
well for white until just two moves ago
or three moves ago when he made a
miscalculation and
look how much he's suffering now look
how much
uh kind of frustration there is in his
face and we have to show what just
happened it actually stemmed from three
moves ago uh if we backtrack to this
position white has a very healthy
position here
white can play a whole bunch of moves
white can push a pawn to kick back the
black bishop this is part of the
flexibility we were talking about white
can capture a pawn in the center white
can for example create a pin on this
diagonal lots of moves here
hans i think relaxed a bit too early he
brought his knight forward but after a
four series move a trade another trade
and a capture here he forgot that after
pawn takes pawn the white bishop cannot
go and recapture this pawn now
white would have an advantage if it
wasn't for this one move black's pawn
pushing forward hitting this bishop and
wherever the bishop goes next move
whoops suddenly the other bishop is
trapped this bishop now is doomed it's
trapped by a pawn and black wins
material so that's why we saw hans just
slapping his face talking to himself
frustrated but fair play to him he's
battled on and if we catch up to the
current game position we saw that white
couldn't take this pawn earlier instead
he's just had to ignore it
and uh black therefore has had the
opportunity to start pushing pawns
himself and this threat is still in the
air this pawn push is really scary to
deal with and i think hans needs to
try and fight against this kind of porn
wedge that black has got going in the
center indeed he pushes forward this
pawn at least now after this pawn push
which aronian plays instantly at least
white now can counter-attack against the
black knight and i'm really shocked that
erroneous playing so quickly
why
he could have paused maybe he had
stronger moves but uh in the end after
taking this bishop now hans has to
decide does he trade off a set of rooks
first or does he go and recapture this
black knight black will still be a pawn
up in most scenarios but
uh at least hans is not dead yet he
still has fighting chances and as we see
there just a rook trade
uh the black knight disappears and after
a train of pawns as well this capture i
think white needs to break his bishop
out of prison as soon as possible he
needs to push his pawn forward to break
down black's pawn in the center one
thing you can't do is white step back
with your king because actually this
pawn push would be a very famous kind of
scenario with the white bishop trapped
entombed
uh it looks like it's on a dice diagonal
but it can never break through this pawn
in the center and this pawn structure
was made famous by former world champion
kappa blanca
just on the other side of the board so
yeah a dead piece if hans can't break it
out yeah and he is going for it
absolutely needed to do it i mean
it's such an important move that even if
it cost him an extra pawn or something
it had to happen
you don't want to be playing with a trap
piece
and uh okay but now there are
consequences because the white king well
it's sitting there exposed on an open
diagonal so the first move to calculate
would be what happens if the black queen
just dives in gives a check
um
gives a check for example white can
block with a pawn
and then i guess you could make an
argument for taking this guy in the
center but at least now white after a
pawn exchange can swing the white rook
across and this bishop is going to break
out we mentioned it needs to get back in
the game next move once the black queen
retreats somewhere safe the black uh the
white bishop will capture a pawn in the
center white's king's still exposed but
he'll only be a pawn down so ironian
decided i mean maybe this was good for
black but ironian decided
in the end to just gain time against the
white queen
and the white queen moved the black
queen leapt forward as well and i'm
slightly surprised why is aronian
playing so quickly he's won a pawn he's
done half the hard work but accuracy is
still required in positions like this
black's advantage is still decent but
maybe it could have been bigger i'm
really worried about this pawn being a
long-term weakness now for black
and the white bishop has hoped long term
of winning this pawn
what do you think of anchor
i agree with you i'm just really shocked
at how quickly he's playing i mean you
said it before
and i'll say it again he has like
just under 15 minutes
all the time in the world to can sit
there and consider whether he should lap
he should play with his pawn and instead
he's just playing on instincts
and
i think at this level it's too much to
ask
yeah
i mean suddenly you see hans niemann now
compare it to five minutes ago where
he was just distraught he was devastated
he knew that he had a losing position he
blundered upon
suddenly hans has hope
and
it just feels to me as if aronian it's
not been going his way the tournament so
far
we talked about this phenomenon of being
tired and playing extra quick just to
compensate for that to try and get the
game over and done with as quickly as
possible it feels to me like aronian
despite his pawn advantage in the
current position he's just rushing a bit
too much i think he could have wrapped
up this game won it
if
already if he just paused a few moments ago
i mean that's not to say he should have
done the extreme and made the mistake i
make of getting in time pressure and
spending too long and being indecisive
being decisive is good but
having 15 minutes left on the clock
we're nearing the end game
it's unnecessary you need to invest that
time a bit earlier on yeah definitely
and well now it's a hans nieman's turn
to burn some time and he's doing some
right things
he's thinking about what's his target
and he's decided to swap off queens
uh again again unexpected
i i thought that he would keep the
queens on and pile on pressure on the
pawn
and
i have no idea what's happening here
guys
i criticized aronian for rushing and now
hans he barely spent any time he spent
like a minute and then swapped off queen
queens which is one of the biggest
decisions in chess
he's swapped off queens he's ruined his
own pawn structure given black a
beautiful night
maybe it was a good decision
but you can't make it in one minute well
also the white king is in danger right
this pawn structure is terrible for
white not only are you upon down but
yeah you could get checkmated and okay
the white king is marching up the board
but just to show your point of anchor
there are checkmating ideas uh on the
board for example if you go back with
your king
whoops the rook is just gonna come round
and trap you checkmate you this is a
very common pattern with a rook and a
knight trapping a white king even if you
don't step back with the white king
right now where are you going
if you step forward the black king will
just step forward as well
i don't even know what you do with white
here say you move your rook you just get
checked
maybe the black rook just enters the
position as well
what is white even doing the problem is
if you ever try to get active if you
ever try to open the position up for
your bishop as we advocated earlier on
then you just get left with an even
weaker pawn
in the centre of the board this pawn is
a potential weakness i could see ideas
such as the black knight jumping in and
trying to checkmate you there's actually
a checkmate threat on the board
and look at this aronian he's going for
a similar idea he's just completely
ignored his central pawn because he
knows that if it's captured he can just
march his king forward this white king
is actually in a mating that
how are you going to get it out for
example if you push this is a check very
simple check and again exact same
pattern coming behind and check mating i
think this game is going to be a
miniature i think this one's going to be
over in a few more moves
what is a miniature game just a quick
one
exactly normally a miniatures i think
it's supposed to be under 20 moves but
this one is just i mean under 20 minutes
yeah 14 minutes wow
that's neiman what is he doing
it just reminds me of um
i have to be honest here junior chess
you know at the low levels when you
start playing and you know everyone's
playing very very quickly and i remember
my father used to spend a lot of time
telling me off and saying don't play so
quickly and i tried to cheat him try to
like just rub out most of my moves and
he was like what is this
you finished in 20 minutes and you
played 60 moves and well anyway we are
seeing something similar here
it's now 32 moves and hans niemann his
position is just dire the white king is
in big trouble yeah
my king is in big trouble all of white's
pawns are weak
black's rook is about to come down into
the white position
first he knocks back the white king
with a check gaining even more time and
space
i mean they're not even thinking aronian
is 34 moves in
he got surprised on move three and he's
got more time than he started with on
the clock
it feels like a blitz game but with
rapid time control with 15 minutes i
mean this could well be a game that both
players had one minute on the clock like
a bullet game yeah
and the quality
these two they're both fantastic players
but the quality has not been too high
either
often this kind of happens when your
adrenaline is pumping a little bit too
much and you can't calm yourself down
and you end up playing so fast yeah and
uh here we go
hey guys i mean earlier i was surprised
geroni was playing so quickly ever since
that moment he's actually played really
really well but uh
hans neiman when you're on the defensive
rule 101 stop and think slow down the
pace of the game
find your bearings again yes he blunted
earlier but he only blunted the pawn
there was still chances actually his
position improved after he blunted the
pawn quite significantly and look at
hans now he's not even focused he's
looking away is he about to resign
it looks like it it looks like
something's just off the focus isn't
there well okay now he's coming back but
the moves they're just continuing every
second just yeah you can barely pause
the rook was attacking the bishop
and again
i mean what are they doing
i mean i want to sit here and enjoy the
moment explain a few things i want to
calculate myself to figure out what's
going on but they're not letting me know
what are what is this what is the are
they experimenting no i mean if you saw
this on and over the board game they
would just be banging the clock playing
instantly bang bang bang and uh yeah
everyone would be crowding around i mean
38 moves and lavon has more than 15
minutes on the clock yeah that's the
strangest thing the only time i remember
such a thing happening on the tour
previously was maxine vashi lagrave i
think he played against timor rajabov
and it was like move 40 it was a dead
drawn rook game he had i think 17 18
minutes he'd gained that much time and
then he blundered
so
sooner or later we might see a big
mistake
uh from one of them levon aronian though
he's tried to do some calculation there
now he's leaning back in his chair is
that relaxation is that
knowing he's done the hard work there is
a trick in the position and a very
crafty trick actually i'm not sure
whether he calculated this one in
advance or just saw it
kind of spur of the moment but now we
have to jump in because knights are so
tricky if rook takes porn
looks like white is starting to fight
back getting back into the game winning
a pawn back maybe creating some checks
but this would be
met by a cold shower the knight dropping
back hitting the rook hitting the bishop
that's a fork and the bishop isn't
actually protected because of a pin
along this third rank so for example
after the rook moves across trade
and white pawns all fall like dominoes
these two pawns will win the game next
move this one dropping as well
instead hans had to find another
solution he moved his bishop
and uh now some now i'm expecting lavon
to take nope he didn't take a pause
i was expecting you know him just to
calm down no this is his full back
option just protect the pawn but it's
also possible to jump forward of the
night and uh lavon just simple chest
defends the pawn
and uh okay is there any hope for hans
newman to save this
difficult
difficult that you know difficult rook
and pawn ending because
white's pawn structure is just terrible
none of the pawns are connected they're
all weak
and
levon has this perfect pawn structure
especially on the right he has the
golden type of pawn which is past pawn
and a protective pass pawn at that
all right well hans is he's ticked under
10 minutes on the clock now but he's
definitely not
looking happy the young american he
started with a joe barba london his
favorite opening but it hasn't gone his
way this game
yeah it was just that one blunder and
we always talk about mistakes being
natural they're a part of chess everyone
makes them but recovery recovery that's
the key
and uh i think that one does come with
experience so
19 years old
yeah i'm sure he's decent at recovery in
general but
this game
he's been lacking yeah that was his
downfall
yeah and he will have the whole
afternoon maybe even evening to think
about what's gone wrong i i really liked
sam savion's uh
uh way of coping with this kind of
tournament because you you get enormous
pressure from playing such of the these
games and even if you're doing well or
doing uh badly you know you still get
the adrenaline rush and you still get
that rush of emotions and i liked what
he said you know he just took a walk
and then uh you know he just chilled a
little bit and then to work
and what was quite noticeable was that
he changed his schedule we also saw we
also had pragnanda last uh in last
month's
no maze tournament
that he also changed his schedule so
that he would be training and playing
late in the late at night and in the
early morning
and uh
mentioning pragnanda in that oslo
tournament didn't he have
a performance rating of three thousand
close to three thousand was it three
thousand i think around there after the
first few days yeah i mean it was just
incredible he was winning all his
matches in three games it was best of
four he would always win in advance and
i mean that if he'd been able to keep it
up that would have been maybe the best
tournament uh performance in history
against such elite opposition but yeah
um obviously it's hard after
kind of a prolonged event to maintain
that kind of astronomical level of uh
thought that win rate but maybe we could
see it again because uh sam savion has
won four games in a row and uh his uh
performance rating is now
uh three thousand oh yeah sam savion
he is not playing this round because
it's a walk over win uh against timor
ajabov but the 3000 was before this game
so i mean if he keeps winning
wow
very impressive i think he's got 20
points after this round out of a
possible 24 that's i mean i don't think
we've seen it at this stage
even the likes of magnus carlsen have
struggled to hit those heights normally
there's a few more draws along the way
yeah well defeat hero there not yet for
some seven and he's met many of the
higher rated players he beats the von
neuronian so these youngsters wow they
are playing some impressive chess hans
niemann's struggling a little bit and
definitely in this game do you still
think it's going to be a quick game or
will they keep fighting he's uh he's
drawing it out
but if you look okay this last pawn has
dropped but black does have two uh past
spawns now the h pawn and the b pawn
more importantly a two pawn advantage
look at the white king as well
dancing into some very weird squares
and look at this checkmate is about to
happen look at hans neiman he reacted as
if it's a surprise that he's losing this
game but checkmate's coming the black
brook is just going to swing the whole
way across behind the white king and
this stuff can happen if you rush if you
don't think
yeah and
there we saw him cursing and
expecting the game to be finished
any second now okay so he's just pushed
a pawn forward well that's not going to
help matters it's just delaying the
inevitable and there you go we have a
result levon aronian wins
and it's over
hansa niemann loses to levon aronian